ja es geht ich mache heute einen
spaziergang mit einem kumpel mit diesem
cockpit und ich dachte mir ich
beantworte beiden vertragen
you know how you know how in der liste
frau gefunden
ich habe dich so ich habe hier fragen
einmaleins welche der zauberkräfte
möchtest du haben durchsichtig werden
fliegen gedankenlesen fliegen wenn ich
am coolsten weil wir wenig fliegen und
durchsichtig werden keine ahnung ich war
noch nie so der typ der gerne im
hintergrund steht oder so und daher
würde ich gerne fliegen können ja
fliegen wer cool gedanken lesen wir zwar
auch nice aber ich glaube das willst du
teilweise gar nicht von daher ist glaube
ich fliege nicht am besten so nächste
frage welcher ist deiner meinung nach
der beste ort zum nachdenken und wie sie
sagen das ist und da ist einfach der
akku leer gegangen ja leute der beste
ort zum nachdenken ich werde jetzt
einfach die nächsten fragen hier im
schnitt beantworten
der beste ort zum nachdenken ist meiner
meinung nach nicht so definiert weil für
mich muss man zum nachdenken irgendwie
ruhe haben und ich mag super gerne wenn
ich irgendwie an der frischen luft bin
keine ahnung also irgendwie unterwegs
deshalb mache ich auch relativ häufig
irgendwie spaziergänger aber ich finde
man kriegt dabei übels den kopf frei und
es ist einfach mega cool
außerdem liebe ich einfach wald und
natur generell und ja also ansonsten
wenn es irgendwie ein fester ort sein
müsste würde ich sagen die terrasse wenn
es still ist
so eine sehr passende frage für heute
versteckt ihr noch ostern versucht ihre
ostereier und ich habe heute selbst der
osterhase gespielt ich war nämlich nicht
dabei in der kirche meine mutter meine
schwester waren der kirche ist doch ganz
lustig wenn ich mal austeilen spiel ist
habe ich meiner mama gesagt ich mach das
und habe das zeug versteckt ich
persönlich hatte früher immer das gefühl
dass diese sachen alles so mega leicht
versteckt sind dass man als direct
finden nicht mehr so mühe gegeben und
meine schwester ist einfach
durchgerutscht und hat es in der halbe
minute alles auf gesammelt was sie davor
in ihrer minuten langer arbeit versteckt
habe
naja schade so nächste frage gehst du
lieber feiern oder bleibst du gerne zu
hause mit freunden das ist relativ
schwierig weil ich mag irgendwie beides
super gerne wenn ich mich aber
entscheiden müsste wäre ich glaube ich
eher der zu hause bleibt typ
das kann bestimmt auch luca und
sebastian bestätigen die mich immer
wieder dazu quälen wie die mich cern
dass ich einfach noch ein paar stunden
mit gehe ich mag beides echt gerne nur
ich bin selten in feierlaune irgendwie
also ich habe selten lust irgendwie
meinen acht umzuschlagen
nur um dann halt super viel geld im club
zu lassen oder vielleicht zu riskieren
dass man nicht rein kommt und so was das
finde ich ein bisschen stressig ich
würde fast sagen ich bin da so bequem
dass ich gerne auch zu hause chile so
nächste frage welches teil der maus
kollektion gefällt dir am besten
das kommt mir häufig die frage die marge
koalition kommen wir am ersten april auf
markt.de raus 6 und wir haben ja ein
gelbes ockerfarbenem t-shirt die genaue
bezeichnung lautet glaube ich kam melo
dann einen schwarzen krunic und einen
pinken rudi ich finde den pinken wurde
irgendwie am coolsten ich weiß nicht das
ist halt vollkommen untypisch also
zumindest dafür let's play offs ich weiß
nicht ob ich da schon jemand irgendwas
pinkes gesehen habe und ich mach das
irgendwie auch als ich ihn selbst
getragen habe aber wir wollten nicht
wissen wie nicht einfach angeguckt wurde
in fällen als ich damit um gelaufen bin
weil ich mich noch nicht wieder
umgezogen hatte
aber das hier natürlich nicht davon ihn
zu fragen wenn ich bock drauf habe
aber ich würde sagen das sei dass ich
wahrscheinlich am häufigsten tragen
werde
ist wahrscheinlich erwachte schwarze
krunic nächste frage welcher ist ein
lieblings actionfilm das wäre dann
wahrscheinlich wenn ich freue mich schon
so krass auf dem jetzt läuft ich freue
mich schon so krass auf den neuen film
märz kommt auch welche nicht mag dass
die captain america gegend kämpfen dass
ich finde ich doof wie sonst aber almen
wäre wahrscheinlich mein lieblingsfilm
ich weiß nicht genau welchen teil
einfach alle drei die bisher aus dass
als unesco jung wat habt ihr da häufig
gestritten
finde ich ist eine sehr gute frage weil
ich denke mal in den videos gewinnt man
so den eindruck und das ist auch
wirklich so dass wir uns richtig richtig
gut verstehen das war tatsächlich nicht
immer so also wir hatten zeiten da haben
wir beide relativ und korrekte
verhaltensweisen gegenüber dem anderen
gezeigt
sebastian war halt immer so nah wie soll
ich sagen nicht aggressiv aber immer
voll fies zu mir und hat mich gehauen
und sowas
ich habe teilweise wirklich so
provoziert und bin dann irgendwie petzen
gegangen zu unserer oma oder sowas und
habe ihnen dann eher schlecht dastehen
lassen das war auch echt also viel mehr
aber ich bin sehr froh dass das wäre
schon super gutes verhältnis haben sie
wenn du siehst ja das wartet jeder sagt
duh und luca sind brüder stimmt das
eigentlich nein das stimmt nicht
luca und ich sind einfach nur gute
kumpels und nicht verwandt mein einziger
bruder ist der sebastian also der spd so
ich weiß auch gar nicht wie lange das
ganze jetzt war aber ich fühle mich als
hätte ich ein paar noch nicht allzu
häufig dagewesene fragen beantwortet
kleine bitte an euch wenn ihr fragen
stellt bei sowas dann seid ihr ruhig ein
bisschen kreativ
weil es kommt halt voll häufig erstmal
diese vollidioten immer darf ich das
video beenden weil sie halt unbedingt
rein wollen das genauso schlimm wie
diese ist ein leichtes für top kommen
bring dich um es kommen einfach total
viel quatsch so wie geht es dir
womit du noch mal hin und sowas sind wir
alles zu fragen die man schon tausend
mal bekommen hat also wo ich gerne
kreativ sein und desto interessanter
wird dann auch das video wo ich
beantworte okay leute dann würde ich
sagen was das von heute ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und wir sehen uns bald
wieder wenn ich wieder im video mache
ich irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig für
mir zurzeit mit dem täglichen content
weil ich nicht genau weiß was ich
täglich bringen möchte ich habe derzeit
nichts wo ich sage das bring ich tag für
tag darauf habe ich bock
deshalb sind die videos in letzter zeit
ein bisschen unregelmäßig ja okay das
war's